after years away from theatres the Blade
franchise is coming back but it has a
new leading man
why did Marvel decide to go with Mahesh
doraleous as new blade instead of
sticking with Wesley Snipes while we
wait for the characters phase 5 MCU
revival here's everything we know by
August of 2019 Wesley Snipes will be 57
years old
granted slopes as aged well and we're
willing to bet the guy who gave us the
martial arts moves we saw in as many
action Flags can still throw a mean kick
also ages meaning less and less these
days when it comes to custom Harrison
Ford was 65 when Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull was
released in theaters and even though
he's now in his late 70s he'll return to
the role again in Indiana Jones 5 not to
mention the impressive advances in the
aging technology something Marvel has
already used successfully a number of
times to impressive results do me a
favor try not to burn the house down
before Monday okay so it's Monday that
is good to know I won't plan like toga
party accordingly but there are
differences between those examples and
the potential of casting Snipes has
played the most glaring issue being that
played part vampire a 77 year old
complain Deana Jones because in this
human in the first blade film series
it's established played ages normally
but in the comics Walt blade isn't a
mortal like for vampires the ages lower
than humans the new blade films may be
closer to the comics in this way if so
having a 57 year old half vampire who
looks like he's 57 doesn't work largely
thanks to a 2012 AV Club interview with
Patton Oswalt about his most memorable
roles where's the Snipes opposed
behavior on the set of played Trinity
has become absolutely hilariously
infamous if you just sit and watch play
Trinity it's a d-minus it just doesn't
work but if you know what they went
through to get that movie made yeah it
is an a Snipes and Trinity director
David Goya didn't get along behind the
camera according to Oswald's swipes
accused Goya of racism and at one point
sat down with the director and tried to
convince him to quit
only to have Goya retort that sins had
already filmed all of Snipes as close
ups and could use a stand-in for
everything else
Snipes should quit instead Oswald said
after that confrontation Snipes refused
to communicate with Goya directly after
a while he resorted to just give he
would communicate with with post-its
that he would give to the director and
each one he would sign blade
blade Trinity came out well over a
decade ago
and it could be the snipes has mellowed
with age regardless Marvel will probably
try to recruit some impressive director
or talent for the new blade film and
doing that will probably be easier
without a lead actor you can't even get
to use his words come on huger works but
it could be that any concern about
Wesley Snipes for turning to play blade
as baseless but that still doesn't
change the reality that we got to see
Snipes play played in three films
bringing him back to the role would
waste a marvelous opportunity of finding
a new actor to give a different shade of
blade but Ursula Ally is a tremendous
catch we don't know much about the film
yes including us release date but we
know plenty about Ally's Talent he's got
two Academy Awards for Best Actor in a
supporting role under his belt one for
2017 moon lights and another for 2019
screen book
he's brilliant as political consultant
Remy Danton in house of cards as well as
the villain cottonmouth in the first
season of Luke Cage any Marvel fan any
blade fan or just any person with even
slightly good taste should be thrilled
about the casting it looks like it looks
like you brought your own hat my Hershel
ah you did what is that
[Applause]
just because wesley snipes won't be
returning ass played doesn't mean he
won't be in the film when it comes to
paying tribute to writers artists and
actors Marvel Studios has a fine track
record and there's no reason Snipes
couldn't fill another role in the
upcoming blade
one perfect choice could be the role of
Whistler blades mentor slash father
figure Kris Kristofferson played
Westerner in the original film trilogy
and Snipes could be perfect casting for
the rebooted character how do you feel
like hammer we're not the first ones to
have the idea immediately following the
news of Ali's casting as the new blade
stipes fans reacted quickly many
accepted the new casting but with the
preference or they wanted Snipes in the
film in some capacity even if it was
just a cameo and more than a few fans
named Whistler as a perfect fit
since we know stipes talked to Marvel
about something this may already be in
the works in a couple of years we could
see Snipes yelling at Ally for saving
vampire bite survivors and chain-smoking
or spilling gasoline all over the place
whatever his reputation for onset
shenanigans might be you've got to give
wesley snipes this much after the news
broke that Marvel had hired Maher Sheila
Ally to play the rebooted played the og
day Walker took a publicly in stride
waiting a few days for things to settle
down before talking to the press and
assuring his fans that he supports the
studio's decision swipes addressed his
fans in a statement writing in parts
toward the day Walker's losing their
minds right now chillax
although the news comes as a surprise
it's all good such as the business of
entertainment much peace to the MCU crew
always a fan congratulations and Salaam
to Mahalo LA a beautiful and talented
artist whose expressions I look forward
to experiencing for many years to come
whether Snipes Magnum honest reaction
stems from a secret involvement in the
new blade or simply some good
old-fashioned maturity because anyone's
guess at this point either way it looks
like everyone's happy with the way the
future of the franchise is shaping up
even if the man who originally brought
the central character to life has ended
up losing the role and the process
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]